lo que haremos en este vídeo es pensar
las diferentes maneras en las que
podemos llegar a 5 ya qué me refiero con
eso a pues mira aquí arriba tengo 3 más
algo y ese algo este algo que es
incógnito es un misterio nos dará 5 en
el diagrama que tenemos aquí abajo
tenemos ya tres círculos azules que nos
representan
este número tres pero tenemos cinco
casillas y hay que llenar todas 1 2 3 4
5 cuántos círculos más requiero para
llenar estas cinco cajas si ya tenemos
aquí tres que han estado llenas pues
claramente podemos ver que tenemos una
dos libres así es que llenaremos estas
dos cajas con círculos para completar el
número cinco al que hemos de llegar
vamos entonces a colocar las pelotas en
estas dos cajas
y 2
ahora ya tenemos un total de cinco
círculos llenando las cinco casillas que
teníamos disponibles tres azules y dos
de color magenta y con eso podemos ver
que tres más dos será igual a cinco
entonces colocaremos con número
las dos pelotas que hemos puesto y
diremos que 3 + 2
es igual a 5 entonces nuestro número
misterioso que teníamos aquí fue el 2 3
2 es igual a 5 ahora vamos abajo tenemos
una vez más 5 espacios por rellenar y
claramente podemos ver que ya tenemos 2
1 2 sin embargo ahora tendremos otro
número misterioso el cual nos dirá que 2
más
ese número misterioso será igual a 5
como les decía tenemos 5 casillas ahora
pensemos cuántas estrellas más
requerimos para llenar las casillas pues
podemos añadir una
y 3
y con estas tres estrellas ya hemos
rellenado los cinco espacios que
teníamos en esta rejilla dos de ellos en
color magenta o rosita y tres más en
azul por lo tanto podemos decir que 2
más 3
este 3 representa a las tres estrellas
azules que hemos colocado será igual a 5
2 3 igual a 5 y si efectivamente nuestro
número misterioso esta vez fue 3 2 más
nuestro número misterioso que ahora
sabemos que es 3 es igual a 5 vamos a
hacer un poco más de estos haremos
espacio y seguiremos practicando
ahora tenemos un 4 más un número
misterioso el cual nos dará por
resultado una vez más 5 y esta vez los
invito a que ustedes paren el vídeo y
piensen cuál sería este número
misterioso vamos a trabajar con este
vídeo tenemos 4 cajas llenas de estas 5
posibles que tenemos y nuestra pregunta
será cuántas más requerimos llenar para
llegar a 5 pues es muy evidente y está
muy claro que tenemos 1 2 3 4 que
representan a este número 4 y solo nos
queda una por rellenar así es que
pondremos aquí un cubo para que tengamos
las 5 casillas llenas
ok coloquemos la entonces en su lugar
tenemos una sola casilla por rellenar
con este cubo
perfecto de esta manera tenemos que 4 +
será igual a 5 tenemos cuatro cubos
amarillos uno dos tres cuatro y nuestro
número misterioso que esta vez fue uno
cuatro más uno es igual a 5 ahora vamos
a hacerlo de otra manera ahora tenemos
las cinco cajas y solo una de ellas está
rellena por lo tanto requeriremos pues
colocar cuántas caritas felices o este
otro número mágico este otro número
misterioso el cual nos dirá que uno más
que número es igual a 5
hagámoslo gráficamente y rellenamos las
casillas faltantes para saber cuántas
caritas felices hemos de colocar y con
eso completar nuestra rejilla
colocaremos una
y 4
hemos rellenado con cuatro caritas
felices para completar nuestra rejilla
entonces podemos decir que uno esté uno
que tenemos aquí de carita feliz blanca
más 4 o 4 caritas felices amarillas nos
llevarán a 5 coloquemos nuestro número
misterioso que en este caso fue 1 2 3 4
414 es igual a 5 y entonces aquí podemos
ver un patrón vamos al principio para
que lo noten
32 es igual a 5 lo mismo que 23 es igual
a 5 cuando teníamos tres casillas
rellenas nos faltaban dos para llegar a
cinco y cuando teníamos dos de estas
casillas rellenas nos faltaban tres para
llegar a cinco pueden ver aquí que tres
más dos es igual a 23 ambos nos llevan
al resultado de 5 y es exactamente lo
mismo aquí abajo
donde cuatro más uno es igual a cinco
y 14 es igual a 5